when you have a producer like that
that's on set every day that really
knows the crew that knows what's
happening you can really make the safety
net that I never experienced I just
always said to them even if I'm not
there because I did go back and forth
call me I'm on my phone like
you don't have to go to anyone else it's
a safe place and I just I basically did
for them what I wished I had had
a Joint Task Force investigating the
wildfires we're looking for any of the
kids who are on that school bus I think
it can help you
oh my God we're gonna get you out of
here
wolf pack is upon us how are we doing
good good oh my gosh Sarah first I'm
gonna start with you because this is you
know you're back in the Supernatural
what brought you back in initially I
would say Jeff Davis I honestly and I've
said this and he knows I didn't even
intend to read it in the beginning when
it got sent and my team said you know
you should just he's a great writer like
it's just it's it's a great read and
then I read it and I was like oh dang I
was like this is really a fun ride and a
fun statement piece I think for me
what's great about genre is you're
answering the unanswered all of these
stories came from the past when there
were things that couldn't be explained
and Jeff is utilizing the monsters in
this sense to discuss anxiety fear and
what it's like to find your pack and I
it resonated with me having experienced
obviously all of us the last couple
years of covet and being isolated and
understanding that without my pack I
wouldn't have been able to survive and
that's the core of the show and then on
top of it it's just a really fun ride
you want to tell them everything all the
secrets that could get us killed that's
their secret too
there is a giant mystery here and I just
need to know what it is Rodrigo what
pulled you in well it started with just
you know reading it's the first time I
Avenger myself into the supernatural
world the fact that Sarah was on board
made a huge difference that's real not
because he's here
um
you know uh and but when I read the
script I just I I really liked it I'm
like this is a great you know it's great
story I love the characters I love the
character they offered me and it was
sort of like a no-brainer in that way I
said I like it and that was it I think
everybody wants to be in this time it's
like you want to be that water cooler
show you want the show that people are
talking about they can't wait questions
and I always say I almost liken this
show to sixth sense in a sense because
at the very end you almost need to go
back and watch because there's
breadcrumbs dropped throughout that
explain things that you won't realize
that you registered until the very end
and to me that's so exciting and I think
the other answer to that question is
Jeff Davis it means a lot of the credit
yeah it was such an incredible
experience from start to finish it
really
was that experience you hoped for on a
job it was communicative it was
collaborative very much right it was it
it really had what you hoped for from a
job yeah yeah and then we have this
wonderful young cast and I just spoke to
um Chloe and Tyler they were singing
both your Praises she's fantastic I mean
she's been so kind and sweet from the
minute that we met her and has just let
us know that we have a safe space to
come to her and ask her questions yeah
it's been great yeah like for you know
the legend she is in the industry like
what a humble and genuine person project
he goes spits wisdom to us every day
he's he is so grounded and kind he just
truly loves like the craft of acting
like he truly sees like he'll show you
like different different methods or
Styles or like things that I remember
the first time he sat down with us we
talked to him for an hour and I was like
my whole view on acting just changed
well they they taught me too you know I
uh
um you know like Tyler when he would
come and you know ask questions about
you know what's my process and it isn't
that I'm like you know we talked about
it uh but
I learn a lot from those kids you know
um they're they're very talented they
don't have much experience but there was
something about just the way they were
they got involved with the story and the
way they were on set that it just I was
able to learn uh especially being so
long in this business sometimes you know
my tendency is to get so concentrated
that you can get like rigid and working
with young you know younger actors kind
of like helped me out it was
invigorating it kind of like helped me
out too hey take a break now take a
breath you know go there have a
conversation
um so it was an exchange I wouldn't say
I taught them you know uh I I think it
was an exchange that's awesome and then
Sarah for you they were talking about
just how you made the set feel so safe
what kind of steps do you feel like you
take to ensure that that happens on sets
now when I sign on to the show it was
important to me to be an executive
producer not in Maine I mean I think
that there's something that people don't
realize when you have a producer like
that that's on set every day that really
knows the crew that knows what's
happening you can really make the safety
net that I never experienced and I just
said to them and by the way not just
them I said it to crew members too you
know I remember at one point we were
worried about Chloe driving she was
working these crazy hours and I was like
guys we need to get our car like to be
able to sort of see those things
firsthand and understand that there are
answers to those and I just always said
to them even if I'm not there because I
did go back and forth call me I'm on my
phone like you don't have to go to
anyone else it's a safe place and I just
I basically did for them what I wished I
had had so this is how it starts it
fangs get Claws and then we start
killing people
what are you worried about who gives you
up at night now these two characters
Kristen and Garrett they when we meet
them I'm like okay we have a fire
investigator we have Park Rangers like
an adoptive Dad I'm like there is so
much more here can you tease like what
how deep we get with these characters
are there is there a lot to be revealed
here nothing is what it seems and I
think that's you really have to stick
with it I remember when I when I finally
sat down with Jeff and I had my guesses
it's what I thought and usually I'm
pretty spot on and some of them I was
raped but some of them I was so far off
and also I think we have to speak about
the fires I think that's such an
interesting backdrop because it's so
much people haven't really explored that
I for one in the last La fire we were
evacuated at two in the morning for two
weeks we didn't know if our house burned
to the ground and those emotions are you
know you try not to tie your life to
things but our life is a collection of
those experiences and those things
represent that and and what that does
and just how scary fire actually is it's
its own character and we talk a lot
about what we're doing to our Earth and
there's this whole sort of Side Story of
that which I I find fascinating and I
learn all the time and also just the
anxiety portion Jeff and I were having
this whole conversation last night about
we look at anxiety as almost
um
a bad thing right it's a
whereas I need to find what that word is
but the devil you're devil right it's
but actually it's a power and it means
that your body is working at Peak
capacity and how you can utilize that to
to be your power and I think in this day
and age we're all experience anxiety and
for all of us to sort of learn how to
make it our power not our problem I
think a show like wolf bear can play a
major role in you know changing uh the
trajectory of a youth and those terms
just by normalizing you know
conversations that have been stigmatized
for for so long you know so uh talking
about mental health uh all the
characters I mean Armani's character
Everett like literally is having uh
panic attacks and dealing with that all
the time but all our characters go
through and are exposed to stress and
and very you know critical feelings of
anxiety and how to deal with it it's
very it's what we're going through and
their reactions are also different you
have Bella's character who has given up
all devices and you realize that that's
not the answer either because they also
do provide a safety net and a connection
and a security and you have you know
Chloe's character who's looking for that
pack and I even see it in my own
daughter in high school or middle school
where she's looking for who her people
are and she can't quite find them and
she knows they're out there and that
loneliness that comes from not having
that person and then you have Tyler's
character who has really tried to figure
out his place with his father and being
a man and what that means to go from boy
to man it's just such an interesting
progression and
we we delve into it with each of them
[Music]